very big news that i want to couch in
some factual realities
joe biden yesterday signed an executive
order
directing the justice department to end
its use of private prisons joe biden
yesterday
telling the justice department end the
reliance on private prisons
acknowledge the central role that the
federal government has played
in implementing discriminatory housing
policies
and joe biden made some remarks before
signing these orders saying that the us
government needs a completely new
approach to the issue of racial equity
he said the country is less prosperous
less secure
because of systemic racism saying we
must change now it will take
time but we can do it and uh biden
called on the justice department to
curb the use of private prisons uh right
away
now i think that this is very important
we've talked before about private
prisons
versus uh public prisons but there are a
couple caveats here and i want to be
really clear
i'm not reigning on joe biden's parade
but what i want people to understand is
the reality of the numbers
first of all in the united states most
inmates are held in state facilities
not federal facilities so in general
when we're talking about federal prisons
it's a slice
a relatively small one of all inmates
generally speaking if you look only at
private prisons
most private prison inmates are in state
private prisons and in fact just a few
years ago
if you look at all inmates in private
prisons
78 of them are in state private prisons
only 22 percent of private prison
inmates are in
federal private prisons so the vast
majority of inmates
and the vast majority of private prison
inmates are
state inmates who would not be in any
way
directly affected by what joe biden is
saying now that being said
it is still very important that joe
biden is doing this number one
the bureau of prisons federal bureau of
prisons recently opted
not to renew some private prison
contracts in the recent months
as the number of inmates has been
dwindling and many were released to home
confinement
because of the coronavirus pandemic this
is the perfect time to say let's keep
going in that direction and and
furthermore
there's no doubt that there are many
states that will take the lead from the
federal government when the federal
government says
at the federal level for federal inmates
we are going to get away from private
prisons
certainly at least the more blue states
and and maybe purple states
um would see that as a signal as the
door opening
for them to do uh the exact same thing
so i i do think that this
is extraordinarily important uh going
forward there's going to be
there's another issue that follows this
which is that there are many
private prisons that have occupancy
minimums
where essentially they have a contract
with the state or federal government
it's mostly state but they're state and
federal
where they say okay we will run this
prison for you
but you need to guarantee us a certain
occupancy rate
if you drop below that occupancy rate
you still have to pay us
as if we were that full and what that
generates
is a perverse incentive to lower the bar
at which you lock people up if we have a
92
occupancy requirement with this prison
but really
we're only using 85 there's
money we're paying as if we were locking
people up even though there's nobody
locked up
let's find some people to lock up so we
get our so-called money's worth from
these contracts
it's completely perverse it's it could
not be a more backward system so
if we are this is a great first step
we're on day seven yesterday was day six
for joe biden or i guess the the
start of day seven yesterday for joe
biden this is a great start there's no
question about it
but if we really want to permanently
reduce incarceration
it's not just about doing away with the
contracts with private prisons
we also need to change the approach
as to who do we even try to put who do
prosecutors even ask for prison time for
that's obviously a much bigger issue and
it's one that we've talked about before
and and will continue to talk about but
i agree completely with joe biden in
doing this let's hope some states follow
suit
and let's hope we actually deal with you
know there there is a trickle-down
effect here
which is what kind of policing do we do
who gets arrested for what crimes who
gets
charged what penalties and sentences
are requested all of that stuff runs
downhill
so to speak and ends up with what number
of people do we have in prisons
and what level of demand do we have for
bunks or
cells i guess is what we would call them
and you've got to start at the top and
allow those changes to trickle down
joe biden here sort of starting towards
the bottom
but that's okay and hopefully he will do
much more we'll have more about this
on our instagram page find us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow